- [Narrator] Scientists in
South Africa were the first
to raise alarms about Omicron.
And virologists in this lab
have been leading the way
on researching the fast spreading variant.
- The variant has been
studied in South Africa
longer than it has been
studied in other places.
And this lets us understand it better
and enables us to kind of
inform the rest of the world.
- [Narrator] These researchers
are pooling their findings
with results from other
labs around the world
and a clearer picture of
Omicron characteristics
has begun to emerge.
They say the strain possibly
causes milder symptoms
but is more resistant to
vaccines and more infectious.
- Early data suggest that
Omicron is more transmissible
than Delta with a doubling
time of about two days.
- [Narrator] As the
variant poses a challenge
for governments everywhere,
we visited this lab to understand
what scientists have
learned about Omicron.
Alex Sigal and his team of virologists
tested the new strain of the
virus against the Pfizer shot.
- So I'm preparing the cells
for infection tomorrow.
So it's all starting here.
- [Narrator] Their analysis
showed that the variant
can partially evade
protection from vaccines
or prior immunity.
- The fact that it's more
likely to infect people
who are vaccinated but
it's less likely to cause
serious illness compared
to the other variants
is exactly what we see
in our work as well.
- [Narrator] Their research
predicted that for people
who have been vaccinated,
effectiveness against infection
is 35% compared with 72% for
people who have been vaccinated
and who have immunity
from a prior infection.
These findings were roughly in line
with another recent real-world study.
But it's difficult to
draw broad conclusions
from South Africa, which
compared with Europe and the US
has a younger population.
It also has a relatively
low vaccination rate
as compared with places like the UK.
While there's still limited data,
Sigal's team has also
observed that symptoms
from this strain might be less severe.
Another group of
researchers in South Africa
found that even though the
number of cases is rising,
the risk of infection
of hospital admission
for infected people is 29% lower
compared with the first wave in 2020.
- So far the infections have
been mild, mostly mild here
and there might be
several reasons for that.
One reason is there's a lot
more pre-existing immunity.
There are a lot more people
who are previously infected
with a different variants
before Omicron came on the scene
and also considerable number
of people now in South Africa
who were vaccinated,
that wasn't here before.
But there might be other reasons.
Perhaps the virus itself
is a little bit different.
This we don't know yet.
- [Narrator] Even if the
variant might be less virulent,
the sheer number of cases could still lead
to a surge in hospitalizations
as the strain seems to be
far more transmissible than others.
- For a variant like Omicron,
it's kind of a Frankenstein's
monster of mutation.
It's heavily mutated.
What that means is it
gains certain abilities.
One of these abilities is to
escape from an immune response
to a previous infection or to vaccination.
And the second ability
is to transmit better.
- [Narrator] That's prompting
governments in the US
and Europe to accelerate
roll-outs of booster shots.
Early studies have suggested
that another Pfizer shot
will increase protection against Omicron.
But the majority of the world's
still hasn't been fully vaccinated.
And South Africa only begins it's rollout
of booster shots in January.
Global leaders are now
weighing the evidence
as they decide what policies to implement
and how to best protect their populations.
- Everybody is of course worried
and they wanna predict
what is gonna happen.
So it's a very much a
globalized effort now.
In South Africa, we happen to have
a very good research community
for infectious disease
and we're able to make a lot of progress
because also, it started
here before elsewhere
and we able to say something
to the rest of the world
and give some predictions.